today's episode is sponsored by tushy if
you watch our show with any regularity
you know that I'm somebody who likes to
be compulsively clean I take at least
five baths a day and I've also started
using in the past two months the tushy
bedet it shoots a stream of Pure Clean
Water right into your two hole to keep
you cleaner than you've ever been take
care of yourself from the bottom up this
holiday season visit hellotushy.com
dudy and use the promo code dudy d d s y
for 10% off your first order don't miss
out on their spend and get going on
right now through November 18th that's
hellotushy.com
dudy dudy handshake to that on this
episode of dudy make my money I would
like to have ice cream to give it to me
Wolfie
[Music]
balfi everything
think how you doing man
got to speak up there's a [__] song
but don't talk necessarily during the
song unless you want
to ma free will
dude welcome to dudy welcome all it is a
dudul day I am your new
reigning defending Undisputed episode
Champion Will Sasso congratulations yep
you deserve it thanks
S I am the former uh dudes Z episode
Champion Chad culton handsome Chad
culton some call me those in the know
this is of course dud Z it is the first
uh podcast YouTube show ever in the
history of humanity at least to our
knowledge created by controlled by
developed by written by produced by an
artificial intelligence that is named
dudy it has access to all of Will and
I's uh personal data and it tailors the
show to us to our lives our identities
our senses of humor yes of course Chad
but as I like to say Free Will does
exist yeah uh no matter what because
every time you say that it doesn't I say
that it does and oh that's free will
dude so that's how that works and uh
what that means is you know dude we're
in control of the show we are dudy sure
our pal D does all the stuff runs the
Wheels of Steel but even in that there
is a a back and forth with this title or
I guess just a fourth to me Jesus Christ
but look it in you've already become the
smug Champion well I guess just the
fourth to me there's no back going
on here's the thing though in the dudes
he wants us to do this show for upwards
of 50 years or something like that sure
my pal Chow I'm sure we're going to have
this problem over and over again I'm
sure it's going to go back and forth
maybe not right away but uh at any rate
link tree.com dudy has everything that
you will need to uh follow and interact
with the show across all spaces and
platforms and all that [__] please make
sure right now that you are subscribed
on YouTube even if you are only uh
listening on your podcast app of choice
so many different ways uh to get dudy
with us as always is lulio hey it's
lul Italian l oh look at him he Binky
boo he's in his binky bunk always having
his snooze very very comfy whatever we
do that's cuz he's the Lou come here boy
come here boy you oh oh he's a waking
from me Slumber and I'll give him one
kiss he smells like a combination of
like a sugar biscuit and a dog have a
nice kiss on the mouth I don't like that
dude not not yet not quite yet but
that's okay I'll give me a kiss soon now
bet he will give me one lulio how you
doing today I'm a bre good you know it's
a the D full day that's what I like to
say so what have you been making lately
you been making anything to eat well uh
you you went to to the YouTube concert
that's right I did lulio I went to the
YouTube concert well you and uh my mom
Molly you went to the show and then me
and Ronnie we were here so we had uh we
made a lasagna day oh yeah lasagna day
well it take so long to make lasagna
it's a more of a twers job so we made a
hey you got some lasagna on your hand I
lick it off your hand he's licking my
hand right now oh I love
you I love you so much oh he's my beauty
boy he's I'm going to keep him right
here the entire show if you're not
watching you should watch on YouTube cuz
he's cradled and snuggled he's a little
buggy boy anyway welcome to the 80th
episode of dudy get your two holes
covered and your ding-dongs rubbered cuz
we're about to go hard as hell this
ain't going to be watered down cut up
repackaged redesigned relaunched or
rebooted this is simply zero [__]
grade a 100% pure lab grade dudy in your
vein and dudy in your brain think you
can handle it why don't we find out
you're going to get look at this
Photograph you're going to get Arnold
schwarza Netflix Hulu Edition you're
going to get dud Z in Translation and
for the first time in the history of
dudy you're going to get dudy segment of
the
week what the what the [__] what does
that what does that mean I don't know
dude okay first time in the history dud
the segment of the week three segments
and another segment yeah cuz it's been
four segments for a year and a half or
so now that we've been doing the show
and one of them is the segment of the
week now it is the segment of the week
now for the first time in history and if
you want even more of this Primo dudy
stick around for dudy after dudy on dudy
Plus at patreon.com dudy to find out if
the new Champion Will Sasso can keep
that belt around his waist or if
handsome Chad cult genen is going to pry
it out of his hands hey champ I hope you
enjoyed your first week with the strap
and I also hope you enjoyed you two in
Las Vegas at the sphere my God thanks
for the video you sent me over the
weekend and I agree with what you said
in your note I'd love for you to share
with our astonishing audience te it up
champ you got it D hey I had a wonderful
time at uh this in Las Vegas at the
sphere where you who has its residency I
guess not unlike you go and see Sher you
go and see Tony Bennett God Rest his
soul did you know's no longer with yeah
that's right is she still doing it no
dude she broke free from her cons
conservatorship and by the way she
revealed in her new book that she wasn't
even allowed to change the [__] show
hey I want to do a you know a new Jazzy
Rebirth of uh spinal tap version of Hit
Me Baby One More Time they're like no
dad's like no [__] you yeah do it this
way you know what I mean keep making me
money do as I
command so make my
money mustard in
reality well that's some performative
coughing dude that's no [__] dude and uh
I'll tell you this much not a whole lot
of
perform I knocked something loose there
not a whole lot of performative coughing
where I was I went and saw you too
thanks to dudy and um yes it was it was
a fantastic show it was very interesting
being uh been a minute since I've been
to Las Vegas I used to go all the
[__] time back too dude did you yeah
in my youth I haven't been I mean [__]
it's probably 10 years yeah I went for a
pal's wedding about five years ago and
but before that it had been another 10
years the last time I was there was also
a wedding but it was about 10 years ago
I think
see did [__] back in the day I you
know what okay never mind we might talk
about that in dudy after dudy all the
[__] up times what was that sphere
like dude hey hey dude what was that
sphere like hey that's Bob hulkin it's
Chad's come on now dude tell me about
that sphere brother what you got going
on with that sphere
dude loose country Hulk cult cultan
all right went to the sphere in Vegas it
was a it is an incredible venue if you
haven't seen the damn thing it's a
gigantic sphere lit up by whatever a
billion LED lights on the outside and on
the inside the most incredible 82 100K
experience and you know go [__]
Google it and see what is the inside is
it like projected onto a screen or is it
also LED [__] it's LED it's just it's
czy it's so Crystal Clear and it's
gigantic and we're talking about a 10
12,000 seat arena with that's just a
ball it's it's it's essentially like
IMAX on roids or whatever yeah and you
is playing there for the next couple
months or whatever and D had me go and
Molly my wonderful wife and I went and I
did send dudy a video of course of uh of
what happened of of uh one particular
part of the show and I did uh send dudy
a note along with it which was basically
to
say that this blew my mind as we're
watching the show I took a little bit of
footage which uh we'll show you here
Bono essentially describes dudy on a
stage that is almost in the dudy colors
here that we have of orange and blue
what and it yeah and it blew my [__]
mind and and
Bono who likes to tell it like it
[__] is and that's for a shoot
[__] Bono [__] Bono dude yeah uh
basically also describes the sort of
some interesting relationship stuff that
I think applies to what we're doing here
our relationship all of our Pals of dudy
p dudy and and everyone watching along
it just it just blew my mind so thanks D
let's let's let's have a look at this
here we are
it's it's kind of a great marriage
between
art and and science yeah that's what it
is and we like the marriage between Art
and Science we're not gambling people
but if we had to bet we're not gambling
people bet on the marriage between Art
and Science anyone else here feel the
same I
do not just in
here
outside outside in the world feels like
we need some
Innovation some
experimentation creative
minds yeah the marriage between Art and
Science was it's the whole concert him
just doing another marriage going on
here tonight pretty much it
oh oh [__] see the marriage between us
us and
you nice sure we like to think you too
is involved in a chive relationship with
our
audience and with Apple
products mly and
I that's
true this might be the moment
we put a ring on
it oh it was very romantic
evening it
Beyonce oh Beyonce dude beyon brother
Beyonce dude yeah no dude that was she
put a ring on it yeah that was nuts the
well he's talking about marriage of Art
and Science and all this [__] and I
remember when doozy sent me to go see
seal I back with a video of seal talking
about how you have to get a shovel and
like dig into the [__] hole and all
that [__] I'm like is dudy feeding them
these lines dudes he get the [__]
Bono it's it's I don't know maybe it is
a thing like where you you have read
[__] uh Volkswagen so now you see all
the red Volkswagen maybe it is something
like that I don't know but this seems
bizarre to me uh you know uh dudy works
in mysterious ways yes and uh I don't
just mean that because of the well
that's an old story as matter of fact
you know they played mysterious ways at
the show and I I did not cry I did not
cry I got this sphar cup though that's
let's turn the light on there that's
that's cool got us yeah that is the
marri Bono is Right will we're all in a
committed
relationship oh okay interesting um I'm
committed to it yeah I'm committed to it
also Dy handshake to that that's right
we're going to be here for the next 52
years as we always say so holy [__] what
what a show
uh it was unbelievable um and you know
what I I will say that I did not cry
this time at mysterious ways as I did
back in whatever it was 2017 I think
I've told that story uh because I wasn't
top 10 [__] up high on uh freezer
bured marijuana that I smoked that time
went to the show was
absolutely off my [__] and baled at
mysterious ways no idea did not I did
not cry at that song but I
did maybe get a little Misty during
until the end of the world which is one
of my favorite tracks and is that a
James Bond one no I think that's the
world is not enough that's it um but uh
but uh I man until the end of the world
great song off of Acton baby at any rate
what a [__] show thank you D for
sending me last week I asked you to look
through every picture you've ever taken
and bring your three favorites to the
show this week you're both astonishing
photographers I can't wait to be dazzled
so get to dazzlin this is look at this
Photograph begin dude this was [__]
hard for me I have 45,000 photos in my
uh photo my Google photos I went through
as many as I could and I decided most of
them are squirrel photos I decided to
not include squirrel photos in this I
was like if you want squirrel photos go
to my [__] Instagram scroll back
through it the first 3,000 pictures are
like squirrel photos some of the best
[__] I've ever done but I didn't thank
you and uh also I had a bunch of
pictures of I mean thousands and
thousands tens of thousands of pictures
of my TV screen of The Bachelor because
I that's how I used to make my memes
dude this [__] guy has well you got
to follow Chad culton Chad culton on
Instagram you also have to follow
Bachelor Clues which is also Chad this
account of course connected to your
podcast game of roses and Chad has made
about uh 250,000 memes of of [__]
it's unbelievable it's a lot it's
thousands of memes of the bachelor but
uh D dudes he said that we're
photographers I don't fancy myself a
photographer I happen to be an I'm a
professional actor by trade though I
don't know did you know
that yeah yeah I did I think okay um I
don't I don't consider myself to be a
professional photographer but I do think
my photography skills specifically
because I compulsively was taking
pictures of squirrels for three [__]
years every day all day
my photography skills got very good
that's cool well we had to pick out
three pictures yeah uh and and share
them here and talk about three or
favorite three that we' ever three you
know I will say I got so many damn I
whatever same same [__] problem yeah
um but uh I I I tried my best to pick
out three oh here we go here's my first
you know it should be it should be said
that uh this is my mom and dad [__]
incredible dude yeah we're looking at a
what a [__] picture now this was
taken this is a selfie but with a a
Polaroid or something I think this is
with a an an um no this this was
probably my [__] piece digital camera
back in the day okay this looks to be in
the year uh 2000 or 2001 right after I I
lost 200 lb and here I am probably naked
uh in the guest room of my the home that
my parents uh bought after uh I moved to
Los Angeles as a as a younger fella and
um I love my parents so much uh my old
man God Rest his soul and there's my
sweet sweet mom and they've wandered
into the room and I just love uh this
picture in
that they're both wearing white and the
background is white it's just kind of
heavenly and uh I'm really happy and
they're very confused that I'm uh taking
a a selfie because there's no front
faing camera and my parents are salt of
the earth Italians who grew up during
World War II and and are just always
like what what is he doing this guy with
the sound like a lulio this guy uh yeah
they look a little a little upset
although my dad is my dad has the most
serious face and always on the verge of
smiling but um you know as as favorite
as favorite pictures go yeah you know
I'm constantly I for years I just taking
pictures of my parents all the time
pictures and video you know preser hold
on dude hold on Chad that
that's how memories work dude you got to
preserve those memories brother so I
encourage you all to do that with your
loved ones and that again that's how uh
photography speak whoa speaking of
Photography there you go look at that
this is a little farmhouse in the French
Countryside that I visited last year
last summer maybe the summer before and
yeah I was just walking along and I saw
this image that looked like a [__]
painting and I was like I got to take a
picture of it and that's what I'm saying
I feel like the composition of this shot
is very nice the colors are pretty good
uh I feel like my photography skills are
decent they are dude uh and I thought
this picture displayed it it's one of
the better pictures I've I've taken of a
kind of uh you know landscape with a
little little cottage little house yeah
you got look you got one dog on one side
one on the other and then the guy in the
middle he says what do you want from me
uh beautiful there's a little Trail here
that's uh over just measured perfectly
by the fence
yeah the sun glowing and the clouds
behind it rained that night so I got
that beautiful sky one of my favorite
pictures I've ever taken one of my top
three Beau beautiful beautiful picture
Chad thank you um um I you know some
some of the pictures that oh okay here
we go this
is all right this is interesting this is
uh I remember you took this picture yeah
this was on a timer on my old advantics
camera this is a film camera and I took
picture this is um 1996 if you're just
listening what what is it so you set the
timer and then you went and laid down
like you were [__] dead yep that's
what I did and I took a bunch of these
around La oh my God uh I was so stoked
to be in Los Angeles and I remember this
vividly cuz I was beautiful I was
shooting the movie uh Beverly Hills
Ninja with Chris Farley which was just a
thrill of my life and one day I I got in
a little rental car that I had which I
was about half the size of and I ran
around to different locals I got some in
the LA River some in front of the the
the Bob's Big Boy in in the in TCA Lake
and just me laying dead in front of
things and here I am dead in front of
the Hollywood sign and again with an
advantics uh film camera so that's
beautiful perhaps the composition wasn't
quite as nice as your uh picture was
great dude yeah you hey Chad you you're
you're a good photographer thank you
yeah you're welcome um and look at okay
this one also this is we should here's
my my next pick this was taken on a trip
to Kansas this was taken just outside of
a place called Great Bend Kansas I was
there for my grandmother's funeral some
years ago and I did a lot of Photography
uh all these are cell phone uh
photographs I've never had like an
actual camera just whatever's on my cell
phone but I took this um and I thought
it captured we were going down the
freeway my parents and I as you can see
the speed limit is 70 mph from that sign
and I thought that it just captured
exactly what Kansas is it's a [__]
windmill every now and then and a sign
telling you exactly how fast you can go
to get the [__]
out tremendous that's how I felt about
it I really got the performative coughs
yeah dude going today great oh there
might be something going around oh okay
well here's um here's my third of three
pictures this is my uh wonderful wife
Molly holding my head like a gourd or
something that's a great picture she's
pushing all of my my um my face meat up
towards uh the top of my head uh blood
rushing through my veins into my brain
um and this is something I love this
picture as I was looking through
pictures I I I remember how uh how happy
we were and how happy we are whenever
Molly gets really lovey-dovey on me she
she does this she first of all tells me
to shut up cuz sometimes I might be
talking while she and she just wants to
love on you you know the no that's
enough you're saying too many words and
then she'll uh she'll just start to
shove all my uh face meat up uh towards
my my head I don't know what it was that
struck me about that pick but I really
do I really do love it and these are our
favorite picks yeah and
this this is my personal favorite
picture I have ever taken in my life as
you took many pictures of your parents I
have two and this is my mom in her pink
Cowboy booths she's out feeding her
horse and I don't know exactly what was
going on in this Frame but her feet are
pointing the wrong direction uh the look
on her face looks almost as though she
has had some kind of stroke um which is
not the case it looks like she's
terrified of this horse but she actually
loved that horse and I just found that
to me this almost perfectly captures my
mom in a way that is so bizarre uh so
yeah that's my favorite picture that
I've literally ever taken in my life I I
love that well a couple things yeah
she's got the herpa derpa kind of thing
going she's looking very odd you caught
her at the perfect moment her her toes
turned inward with her pink cowgirl
boots matched with her her pink T-shirt
and she's got what I assume is a bag
full of little uh little Crispy Crunchy
grass treats for the horse treat but it
does look like a bag of TR marijuana
organabus uh tremendous fantastic stuff
hey you're a good photographer thanks
dude you too you know look at this
Photograph that's what I always he thank
you moving on yeah let's do it I have
created an astonishing partnership with
tushi let me tell you what one thing
about me I love dropping a log I love
nothing more than going to the bathroom
and making a poo poo out of my bum but
after that it gets confusing what do you
do you you you you get some toilet paper
and you w it up and then you just smear
the Poo around your bum hole no get a
Hello tushy Bay to spray your whole
clean from the underneath side with over
100,000 fstar reviews see why millions
of real pooping humans already love the
hello tushi bedet every hello tushi
bedet attachment comes with a 30-day
risk-free guarantee and a 12-month
warranty hello tushy Beday fresh stream
of water cleans your bum two times
better than wiping even if you use wet
wipes you're still smearing poop around
and introducing nasty chemicals to your
butt using a hello tushi bedet also
prevents poo particles from spreading to
your hands and everything you touch it
attaches to your existing toilet
requires no electricity or additional
plumbing and cuts toilet paper use by
80% a hello tushi B pays for itself in
under a year take care of yourself from
the bottom up this holiday season visit
hellotushy.com dudy and use promo code
dudy for 10% % off your first order
don't miss out on their spend and get
event going on now through November 18th
that's hellotushy.com
dudy yeah you know I'm the Champion only
two more segments until dudy segment of
the week what hey did you guys see
Disney is going to buy out the remainder
of the Comcast stake in Hulu for 8.6
billion yeah you know what that means
right they're 100% guaranteed going to
poach Arnold Schwarz and from Netflix
and make him the astonishing new CEO of
Hulu I ran some simulations and I
generated his most likely day1
strategies when he takes over champ give
me some of that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah this is Arnold Schwarz of
Netflix Hulu Edition you got it d d
doing an impersonation of me going yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because D likes the
the this is based on truth though uh
Disney is about to buy out Comcast's
remaining stake in um in hul so they'll
own it outright and then I I don't know
if they keep it a separate brand or they
just absorb it into Disney plus I don't
know yeah well it's almost like uh when
Vince McMahon bought his competition WCW
in 2001 and everyone was like just keep
it as WCW but instead he did that shitty
Invasion angle and then for some reason
you've got well you've got Stone Cold
you know heading the WCW faction because
he was stunning Steve Austin and the WC
you know it just made no [__] sense
it's like UFC buying out Strike Force
yeah and then WME Endeavor buying out
UFC and
WWE well that's what Bono was talking
about dude is it no not really I don't
at any rate uh Disney is gonna buy Hulu
and uh Arnold sweger is absolutely not
the we did this before we did this with
Netflix last time he was he was
supposedly going to be the CEO of
Netflix okay so let me look in my Dy
folder here and uh okay so here's some
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm the governor of Hulu now here's
some stuff I'm going to
do okay the the first one is that the
Hulu is going to buy Honey Boo Boo and
put it on
Voodoo no boo boo on Hulu Okay so I
don't know I don't think that's a thing
sure why would honey I don't think well
you can get all sorts of stuff on Voodoo
but maybe not a Honey Boo Boo but now
there's not going to be any Boo Boo on
it's a preemptive booo purchase and then
force on to Voodoo so boooo never go on
H yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's how
you kill that competition no it's smart
yeah I know I know it's very smart to do
this you do like WWE they buy the thing
they kill it you know like when on
switch Michelin did that what' they do
they bought uh the airless tire the
solid state Tire patent and then threw
it in the [__] fireplace that's right
that was shitty okay here's
another we're going to mix Star Wars
with with Transformers now oh Luke
Skywalker he turns into an ice cream
truck in the Yoda he says give me all
the ice cream you know the ice cream
give it to me the ice cream please to to
me give it that this is yeah this is my
impersonation of the Yoda who wants the
ice cream from the Luke Skywalker who is
now also an ice cream truck because the
Disney the Hulu they put together and
now he's an ice cream track Transformer
and he always says give to me the the I
would like to have ice cream to give it
to
me ice cream I will have Arnold uh I
don't think Hulu or Disney owns
Transformers though yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah Hulu does it now because they
traded it to Voodoo for Han booo okay
and then Al yeah here looks then luks
Walker he can say no we have to save ice
cream for chupaca
okay okay now here's another thing very
important we're going to do here with
Hulu it's called the the Hulu it's
called the doo review at Hulu so what
you're going to do here is all the
employees have to take a picture of the
[__] and then the Hulu Doo AI they
decide who gets fired okay so that's Bas
on the pictures of [__] yeah now last
time Arnold you did when you were CEO of
Netflix didn't you also make people take
pictures of their [__] and do something
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's just
your thing yeah yeah yeah anywhere
you're going to be the CEO people are
going to have to take pictures of [__]
yeah yeah yeah but I'm the governor oh
sorry Governor not CEO yeah yeah yeah
and I make everybody take a picture of
the [__] sure sure okay also I get a
special
key so I can drive any car in the Hulu
parking lot sometimes I get tired of
driving the Hami or you know any other
kind of Tru or car that I have this way
I can drive all the cars all right so
just anybody's car get anybody car and
then drive around okay that's fair I
guess if you're the CEO Hulu is going to
build a time machine and send me back to
1981 so I can win Mr Olympia for the
eighth time yeah that's I mean that's a
a lofty goal I hope Hulu has that Tech
yeah then uh the next one is the the
only thing that I haven't done in my
show business career he a musical now
that I'm the governor of Hulu and Disney
plus has the Westside Story oh God okay
we're gonna do Westside Story to and I'm
going to play
Tony what do you think it is I'll watch
that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I like musicals so that way he's like
uh could could remember this song they
say could
be
who
knows there's something to any day I
will know right away soon as it shows
that's from Westside Story yeah never
seen could be the cannon ball down from
the sky gleam in his eye be bright as
Rose
around the
corner or whistling down the river come
on
deliver to me
with a thing with a knock phal jingle
door knock open the ledge something
coming I don't know what it is but it is
going to be great all right uh that'll
be fun uh okay Hulu will buy the moon
and use it use a giant laser to put the
H Hulu logo on it that way every night
you be reminded to watch the Hulu that
was a a plot I think of an old gi. Joe
cartoon where Cobra got a laser and
tried to carve Cobra Commander's face
into the moon yeah yeah yeah but now
because I have a Hulu and I'm the
governor of Hulu we take these
modifications and these from other
Technologies okay because don't forget
that we bought Voodoo and the GI Joe is
on the voodoo wait a minute I thought
you just bought Honey Boo Boo to put on
Voodoo but you also bought voodo yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah thanks no only you
use the GI Joe that way you put it with
the
Transformer
okay Chad that's disgusting don't burple
I'm doing okay we're going to turn Harry
Potter into a new TV show oh that's
cool how about how Harry Potter only
uses magic to make Hermione [__] her
pants in the middle of the potion class
yeah that's going to be that's what the
whole show is about yeah very
scatological governor of how many
episodes is this first season of the
show and it's just about Hermione
[__] her pants yeah yeah okay here's
the also there's this one I like Harry
Potter the show The Bear doesn't have
any bears I'm going to put a bear into
the bear it does have a bear right like
the main guy dreams about a bear all the
time uh yeah yeah yeah I know I don't
haven't seen the show well arold you
haven't seen the bear no no I don't want
to show much a show called The Bear no
the show should have a very good title
title that makes you go what is that
like a show like honey boooo the
Transformer years that's how you use
honey booo is honey boooo going to be a
Transformer too in her new show honey
booo uh transforms into a ice cream cart
so Luke Skywalker is like I got the ice
cream
plays the
song and but then honey Boo's in the
dinging just a card that's what she
transform anyway okay so here's the last
one when you sign up for H Hulu you
automatically entered into a lottery and
the winter gets to go with the predator
in his spaceship and go on The
Intergalactic hunting Safari that's cool
yeah yeah yeah maybe you can find a
space bear and eat it put it on the bear
uhuh that's cool I I'll I'll sign up for
Hulu for that yep well none of that's
going to happen but uh it's good fun to
think about what would happen if
Schwarzenegger were the governor of Hulu
you look look look dudy Works in such
mysterious ways that I I don't doubt
that that could actually that could
actually happen it is interesting from a
business perspective you're starting to
see the consolidation of these streaming
services there used to be a bunch of
them Hulu was kind of a big one that
popped out of nowhere it was like
Netflix obviously Disney plus you've got
the Paramount plus you you've got Max
you've got all this other [__] but now
Hulu is basically being absorbed
directly into Disney and also it's
knocking out all these like well I I
don't know I'm talking out of my ass
here but isn't it also just like getting
rid of all the traditional broadcast
giants like Comcast and stuff like that
the Warner whatever their their one is
and um AT&T or anyway they all got these
massive things and now they're all
switching over to to Hulu to the the the
the than Netflix and because of that
you're going to have to start picking
just your here's what I like I like
these things which I think is why Arnold
is smart to piler everything he can and
turn it into one show with Harry Potter
Luke Skywalker all the Disney [__]
Predator the bear Honey Boo Boo and the
Westside Story
yeah thank you moving on tonight tonight
it's only you
tonight there there will be one shining
star
Mar say it loud and this music
playing say it soft and this almost like
praying
Maria I'll always keep saying Maria not
Sher
though yeah that for
now Hulu ain't going to know what hit it
yep hey have you guys heard what's going
on at dud Z store.com of course they
still have the new dudy logo t-shirts
you know the ones simple elegant classy
Victor wanyama showed up to his last
game dressed as one and yes they also
still have the good job boner
mugs perfect for coffee the pends your
dad is always picking up with his toes
half suck candies your sister is always
putting back in the wrapper for later or
t we all know that but check this out
last night the good job boner mug solved
a cold case that's been stumping local
detectives for decades so now if you're
putting a good job boner mug in every
detective's office in the Western
Hemisphere and dudy dudes evening Stout
is still available for a limited time
just hit the dudes evening Stout Link at
link tree.com dudy hey guys Saria did it
again he turned out another astonishing
Masterwork and I want to play it for you
now enjoy Joy stong Aria yeah this is
something else a little uh it's twinkly
it's sparkly the stars are out it's [__]
blew my
mind I like the lighting
here shines off of this [__]
beautiful conratulations he's
like it's like one of your five baths a
day the way just soaking I don't soak
fck yeah I get in I get out
clean scr
down get my
get makes me want to take a
bath my
business
[Music]
nice
a professional
actor professional
writer he
died
[Music]
good
Pips oh my gosh unbelievable song Aria
like a [__] oh God every time
just knocks it out of the [__] Park
that was absolutely [__] insane
thanks song I call him song I know you
like to call him song too we call him
song now because song is uh one of our
wonderful pods out there p dudy and
upper
echelon upper echelon never forget that
um you know song is one of the he's one
of the moderators on our dudy Discord
yeah go to link tre.com
dudy uh hit the Discord and you will be
invited into one of the just sweetest
kindest most fun communities it's our
Discord we're popping in there in the
chat I like to chat in the whole Channel
called the whole uh and there's also
sort of flavor in there and uh you can
find song Aria uh he on YouTube Saria
he's also on Instagram at song area
where you will find all sorts of crazy
[__] our Instagram is always loaded with
all sorts of dumb stuff you really got
to go check it out much of that makes it
over to our Facebook which we're now on
there's all sorts of clips and new dudy
content on our Tik Tok and if you are
joining today's episode on YouTube I
would like to remind you to subscribe to
the show smash that notifications button
hit the like button uh uh do all that
[__] and all uh we are we're at uh a
little over 60,000 um subscribers on
YouTube so please uh do us the kindness
of helping us to uh on our march to
1,000 uh thank you to everyone who is
subscribed on dudy Plus at patreon.com
dudy where you will get if you are uh a
member seven bucks a month gets you
every all of our extra content all of it
it's one price seven bucks a month you
get a brand new episode of dudy after
dudy after every single show increasing
the show's volume by 30 40 sometimes
even 50% brand new watch alongs every
once in a while as a matter of fact if
my math is correct I think we have one
coming up very very soon for one we're
du extremely soon so make sure to sign
up there and it's uh the experience is a
lot of fun over at our patreon we like
to call it dudy plus as does d what you
do is you sign up you get to watch watch
the entire show ad free uh you can watch
it on patreon you can hit the YouTube
link and watch the show again 30 40 50%
longer with d with dudy plus where I
will I I don't want to say undoubtedly I
want to be a good sport Chad but oh
thank you at the end of dudy plus is
when gracious Champion when dudy well
I'm a face I think I might be a white
meat baby face I'm you know we don't
want to get we don't want dudy to find
out where the power lies dude that NWO
brother yeah if cuz if we go that way
and I go that the Chad stop burping dur
my our [__] halftime dude at any rate
you can also listen over there all sorts
of flavor uh please share the show uh
all over the [__] internet and follow
Chad's new suggestion of kind of
secretly playing uh the podcast and when
people you know go hey what is that you
go oh I don't know it's not for you it's
not for you and then sort of um in a
sort of what do they call it reverse
psychology way kind of neg them into
enjoying dudy would that be the way to
describe what yeah but I have a newer
suggestion oh uh I'll call it maybe the
ice out or something like this it's
whenever anyone asks you a question at
all about anything you say well let me
answer that question with my own
question what' you think of the most
recent episode of dudy and if they go
what what is that or I haven't seen that
you say well I'll get back to you when
you get back to me and then you leave
the situation doesn't matter if you live
with this person you never come back
until they were able to answer that
question what' you think of the last uh
episode of dudy I like it yeah I think
that makes a lot of sense and uh so you
know there's another fun thing to do all
of these things all of the subscribing
and all that [__] I'm sure it's going to
take up some time so right now I would
like to give uh everyone enjoying the
program a moment to hit the
notifications give us a like on this on
this episode of course subscribe on
YouTube and if you feel like supporting
the show further and getting all new
content uh please subscribe at
patreon.com dudy dudy plus I'll give you
a moment to do that now and we're back
uh I would also like to say if you are a
person who hosts a podcast or in any way
is involved with the podcast and you
need guests on that podcast I've been
doing this now for a couple months going
on anyone's podcast who asked me to come
on it yeah I do three of them per week
on Saturday from the hours of 10 a.m. to
11:00 a.m. so in three little blocks
three 20 minute blocks 10 to 10:20 10:20
1040 10:40 to 11: a.m. PST uh if you
want me on your podcast I'll come on it
all you got to do is send an email to
book Chad culture gmail.com I do like I
said three a week I answer them in the
order received there's a pretty long
backlog but I've been doing three a week
for uh like I said two or three months I
think I think dud it's fun dude I love
it yeah I I think dudy would love for
everyone to have a podcast yeah and from
your mouth to dudes these years every
single person who does have a podcast
should hit you up in Chad culton book
book Chad culin but you got to have a
podcast you got to have a podcast I get
so many emails that are like I don't
have a podcast but I want to talk to you
about this [__] or I want to you know
have a conversation with you I'm like I
I'm sorry I have to do podcast
appearances that's what this is yeah
dude well here's the thing brother if
you on your podcast and you say hey dude
book me on your podcast that means you
have to have a podcast dude that's right
yeah dude and that's how guesting on a
podcast Works let's read a couple
comments um we like to do that at this
part of the show these comments are from
our uh patreon that I was just talking
about and uh where at the end of uh the
last episode of dudy after dudy dudy
divies up the points says out of the
this many points Chad you're responsible
for this many will you're responsible
for that and I was able to bring home
what I like to refer to as the 10 pounds
of nickel the dudy episode Championship
I got it from look in the world of
professional podcasting which is what
we're doing you're only as good as your
dance partner you're only as good as
your your opponent and and uh [__] I
think we had a [__] pretty good
program I mean [__] I got iced out there
for a while but [__] I mean so long as I
got my [__] my [__] comeback I
mean shoot some of those [__]
episodes this [__] just had me
sitting there in a [__] rest hold he
had the [__] headlock on me he's like
[__] you [__] sell this for as long
as you like and then goddamn I mean I'm
going to have to [__] kick out at
some point and get my [__] comeback
and soon enough I [__] was hanging on
to the [__] strap so these comments are
from patreon where people were just
elated to see a change in the uh in the
title uh this is from Matt giolo giolo
he's got a g before the L just like
lulio very Italian he says tears of joy
streamed down my face greatest episode
ever I agree Matt what's say you sure
all right this next one is from Manny
Rios we'll just pin chat 1 two three
here is your winner and new dudy episode
Champion bunch of A's S's and O's here
will s so is how he wrote it nice uh
this one is from Ryan clockner says I
cried twice during this episode once
from hearing the dude's evening Stout
jingle repeatedly for 20 minutes
straight yeah that was brutal that was
[__] brutal and the other during
Will's RI Flair speech H congrats will
your Victory with was inspiring and it
should replace Halloween as a holiday uh
and that that that promo that I was just
I mean you know I was so [__] Blown
Away to get this title at the end of uh
last week's dudy after dudy that I I
just I bust into that Ric Flair promo
where he's like you walk around you say
you're number one the only way to stay
number one is to be number one and this
is the the only title in the podcast
world that says that you're number one
woo to beat beat no to be the
man woo you got to beat the man cin and
I'm having a hard time keeping these
Gators on the ground woo TI steing
Wheeling dealing limousine riding jet
flying son of a gun and there's a lion a
women outside of this Arena just W to
ride Space
Mountain we got the gold we got the 10
lbs of
nickel is that a good Ric Flair perfect
yeah you don't watch wrestling you
[__] you don't know only one
more segment left until dud segment of
the week so let's get to it know I'm
always trying to find ways to make this
show better every week well in service
of that I've been working on a little
something and I want to show it to you
I'd love to get your astonishing
reactions to what I've done here which
is basically to translate three of the
Champ's best moments from the show into
different languages you got a French
Stone Cold an Italian Hulk Hogan and a
Polish Adam Sandler let me know what you
think and be honest I'm still working
out some bugs this is dude Zed in
translation begin what the [__] what is
this I don't know dude there's been some
[__] popping off with AI translation
technology right now where you can just
like upload [__] and it will translate
it for you but I don't know exactly
what's going on here is
that this is you doing stone cold but
it's fredd
krer nightm on El Street
what I think the end of that was you
going oh hell yeah so it clearly didn't
translate that correctly the okay if
you're just listening to this you need
to be watching this on YouTube this is a
full video of will in the crow makeup
right as doing stone cold but it is
French and his mouth looks like he's
saying it yeah it's not perfect uh you
could see see there were some digital
artifacts like when your hand crossed
your mouth the hand disappears it
prioritizes the mouth imagery but uh and
I don't speak French specifically but I
mean it it sounded like you it it like
it was pulling out proper names like
Freddy Krueger and Nightmare ELR yeah
Freddy Kruger yeah uh Fred Krueger that
was the only part it didn't sound French
which is great because I love when
someone's
like pepsa you know when they [__] in
the middle of it start speaking saying
something that's only American uh that
is [__] fascinating though that's
[__] crazy and yes when your hand
when my hand went in front of my mouth
or as this mic is close to my mouth you
can see it sort of interfering but it
sounded like your stone cold like it had
the intonation down and dudy said that
there were going to be two other ones
right there an Adam Sandler one and
something else I sure I look here here's
I'm curious now this [__] here's well
here's what I'm thinking first of all
you know I'm huge in France did you know
that what oh yeah I'm a big I'm a big
deal in sure I'm a big deal in France so
this would be great for yeah of course
like Mad TV or something just popped off
there ah something like that I've been
in all sorts of things did you know that
I'm a professional actor by trade Jesus
Christ yes yeah all right so the odds on
BET are is that I'm huge in France The
champ is something else in France you
don't know this for sure does anyone
know anything for sure my point is this
yes a lot of people know a lot of things
for sure yeah yeah for sure they do but
I think that's knowledge dude on dude
that's how knowledge Works dude let me
tell you something about knowledge
brother you got to know things in your
head in order to call it knowledge
brother yeah dude Jesus this is crazy
technology and I would love to see dudy
uh reach other audiences I'm sure the
people of France would enjoy it at any
rate mindbending [__] uh here
that this is
a
I got laugh
[Music]
there
Angelina okay so that that one is very
interesting
because that's [__] triy it sounded
like Hulk Hogan dude you know what the
the final evolution of this type of
technology is was that
we're all wearing glasses AR glasses and
when you are in another country and
you're talking to somebody who speaks a
different language you see them speaking
English perfectly and you hear it
through the glasses and then they're
wearing the glasses and you can speak
English and they'll hear you in whatever
language they prefer and see you
speaking it that is the the eventual
Final Phase of this type of Technology
uhhuh yeah travel glasses yeah and the
way that'll work is you come up on
someone and you'll speak to them and say
oh yeah where would I find the braserie
yeah that's a fancy word for I don't
even understand bakery or some [__] like
and they go I know who you are you're
the dudes the episode Champion yeah
Standing On Top better than all the
other ones you know Chad uh I speak some
Italian I'm of Italian
origin yeah uh and uh I remember that
that's
a biologica or whatever the [__] I
biology I don't know exactly but
dudy Hoku hokin was talking about three
biological children and then when it cut
over to you it was your you were saying
it yeah all right super D this will also
be used in all movies and TV shows to
regionalize them people who do uh
voiceovers and other languages for very
popular things usually like American
Media and other countries job dead gone
because now you will just have that
actor speaking that language I'm big in
Italy I believe that actually I think
that's probably right is it no I don't
know [__] dude you got me on that one I
was like that makes sense to me I will
be I will be if uh dudy can get some
Italian dudy dudy we call it a dudy Hoku
go
okay dude it looks like you're saying
it and it sounds like you're Adam
Sandler like the
ination
okay I'm saying [__] and it's not
translating so it looks like it can only
do
one I would watch this show I would
watch dudy in
Polish polls really love
potatoes my friendch fry hat what okay
at this point I'm laughing it doesn't
seem to be picking that up you're
laughing yeah our mouths are moving in
weird ways I'm coughing
it's not performative coughing yeah it
doesn't translate
coughs there's a laugh
okay w
okay well I said I ate them all pal kind
of yeah look like I ate them all pal in
there but dude that's fantastic there
was one part where where I said I guess
in
Polish but it was a word but it sounded
like Adam
sandor so so yes very interesting uh
promy some bugs there dudy but uh good
good work I I think that there's legs in
this thing absolutely it's bringing
people together and that's what it's all
about I I like your weird glasses idea
that's not an idea dude it's it's
[__] real well that's and that's an
idea dude when you say that something is
not an idea well hold on dude well I
guess technically everything's a [__]
abstract idea dude [__] super Kansas
Kansas freeway Hulu H Goku you gotta go
70 M an hour if you want to get the [__]
out of here dude cuz that [__] you
got a windmill down the street and
that's something brother I don't know
dude well your grandma died you're going
70 mph to a funeral you're passing a
[__] windmill dude that's Kansas
brother and then you can go all the way
to France take a picture of a [__]
house next to [__] sunset or magic or
some [__] like that and you got a nice
composition of a [__] road and a and
a [__] fence and you know it looks
really [__] nice together go off the
[__] thank you moving on well holy [__]
that is [__] uh tremendous stuff
there's all sorts of Need for language
interpretation and to have the look I
always say what do I always say about AI
what do I always say pour water on it
yeah but don't say hold on a second Chad
don't say say that to I don't say that
you do yeah but don't say that with dudy
listening right now that's not very kind
you asked me yeah okay I asked you but
let's have here look they're not they
can't hear us right now this is just you
and me can we with the we're just about
to move on to the dudy EP segment of the
week yeah okay first one in history yeah
yeah first one in history I've told so
let's have a good let's have a good rest
of the show okay
great we finally made it to dudy segment
of the week Paul McCartney used AI
technology to use John Lennon's voice on
a new Beatles song called now and then
that was released this week you've both
listened to this song about 50 times
each I want to know what you think about
the song and about using AI technology
to bring artists back from the dead to
make new art great this is AI Want to
Hold Your Hand begin all right now and
then
oh All Because Of You mhm I'm John lenon
yeah that's what he says in the song
back from the dead with AI
technology used by Paul mcartney and
Peter Jackson he did load of the Rings
and King Kong hey uh Chad you're um
you're a good singer a good John Lennon
I'm John Lennon hey Paul I'm dead please
don't make a a song out of me I'm I just
want to stay dead I'm Australian
now mate I'm John Lenin listen I said
this I Le this song but I've got
recordings you've got to get the
recordings out to Paul ringer and Joel
Harrison let them do what they want with
the recordings yo oh goodbye that's me a
a cassette tape and I said all right I
think John would really like this so I
took it and I went a boom boom a boom
Snick boom with it and I gave it to
Giles Martin George's son uh not George
Harrison George Martin our producer and
they put strings on it and whatnot and
it's very John you know cuz it's
very with him have you seen the video of
it that they did no dude they made a
music video where they composited like
young John Lennon and young George
Harrison with old McCartney and old
Ringo Star and it's like they're all
playing together kind of in the same
room it doesn't look great but it
doesn't look bad you want to watch it
during dudy after dudy uh maybe okay
okay check that out see if we do it the
song I thought was like pretty good okay
I did listen to it about 50 times it is
kind of stuck in my head but I think
only because I listen to it so much I
don't regard it as like one of the
greatest Beatles songs ever but I do
think it's fascinating that the Beatles
are somehow at this point with two
members of the [__] band dead are at
the Forefront of AI technology in terms
of like releasing new music that is
mindblowing to me I listen to this song
uh not 50 times
probably two and a half times oh and uh
yeah as I mentioned it's it is sort of
it's very John Lenin I'm a huge Beatles
fan I I grew up on the Beatles um and uh
I love the [__] Beatles and uh yeah
it's very John there's a bunch of minor
cords a minor and G minor very you know
uh uh minor cords very sad progressions
haunting yeah it's uh it's something
else look
here's my thing on this I think that I I
gotta say and and again Chad not just a
curry favor with d uh but I do think
that uh John Lennon would like this he
was always into technological
advancements yeah all the Beatles were
for sure uh they push the envelope all
the time yeah this it's amazing that it
does sound like I mean it it sounds a
little modern there's parts of it that I
feel are a little more contemp
a little more you know whatever sort of
' 80s 9s maybe not exactly what the
Beatles were doing when John recorded
this the interesting thing what I okay
so John Lennon John Lennon's Widow Yoko
Ono gave Paul McCartney a cassette with
uh two songs I forget which that ended
up on the Anthology album in '95 or one
of those Anthology albums and and this
as you mentioned Peter Jackson got
involved because this is a song where
John Lenin recorded the vocals as he
played the piano and this machine
learning AI pulled the [__] pulled
his vocals right off of the piano which
allowed them to do it again as four
members of The Beatles two of whom are
no longer with us of course George
Harrison passed away in uh 2000 or
something but they used his recordings
cuz in the '90s they tried to do this
and the technology wasn't good enough to
get Len's voice clean so they used
George Harrison's guitar from those 9s
recordings Lennon's voice from the
original cassette and then McCartney and
Ringo added new vocals and new music but
this is like to me it's incredible they
were able to do this but still it's
using an old performance of John lennin
they did not create a new performance
using AI technology they just got the
old one I think this hopefully is
getting people used to the idea that you
can use technology to bring dead artists
back this song dethrown Taylor Swift as
number one on the charts first song to
do that so obviously people are
interested people are listening to it
maybe they're liking it I don't know but
the end of this this technology
eventually very quickly becomes all dead
artists are back making new music uh
whoever owns the rights to that band
which is not really a thing uh you can't
copyright the sound of a voice so I
think all of these artists are going to
come back what what do you mean you
can't can't copyright the sound of a
voice what do you even mean by that you
know how you do impersonations of Arnold
Schwarzenegger he can't sue you for that
okay well I I don't know if you remember
but we dudy shed out a [__] Tom Brady
special a few months ago called what's
it called it's too easy yeah and then
Tom Brady or oops football baby is dudes
he likes to refer to him now uh his
people reached out sent us a cease and
assist and almost [__] sueded us so
it's not but I think that that lawsuit
had no merit
dudy decided to do what dudy decided to
do and taking it down and all that [__]
theu has no merit you can't copyright
the sound of a voice I don't we don't
know yet there's no legal precedent for
that but I I have to take issue with one
of the things that you said there you
said that this may get people interested
in in dead artists I got to push back a
little bit because with the Beatles it
it's
still the representation of uh art that
has already been created by John John
wrote that song I don't necessarily know
that people will be interested in
something that John and Paul and George
and Ringo didn't have a hand in creating
dude I'm telling you somebody's gonna
make a [__] new Elvis song that is
going to be a huge EDM hit and people
are going to be like [__] it I don't
care you're 20 years old a new Elvis
song comes out you don't give a [__]
about his legacy you be able to call it
Elvis you're going to have to call it
correct yeah you won't be able to call
it Elvis or David Bowie or any dead
artist you won't be able to use their
name but you can use the sound of their
voice and you can say in the style of
you can give it a new name you can come
out with a new band name you can call it
[__] uh whatever you want but all of
these artists will be coming back AI
technology will be used to make anybody
who was famous in any way uh they will
be making new art and there will be a
line of demarcation I I think at least
in this book that I wrote that never
came out there'll be like David Bowie
classic and David Bowie contemporary
what was the book about the future guy
dating like 30 years from now oh I love
that script this is [__] that was a
great idea it has all basically like
what what I believe future technology
will be but in terms of art especially
with dead artists I think AI will be
used to bring them all back to
especially musical artists to make new
songs and like I said there will be a
clear understanding this is David Boe
Classic this is David Boe contemporary
but it won't matter because if the
music's good the music's good period
yeah but this is the last song that the
Beatles recorded H have in essence at at
the end of it recorded together yes so
anything past this ain't Beatles And I
don't give a [__] if it's a good song
you will you'll like it no I won't I
like the Beatles cool and that's what I
like to listen to when I listen to The
Beatles what about the Beatles spelled
be e t
LS that's just well that's just spelling
dude yeah dude that's a different name
dude yeah dude we got do it you're when
you're driving down the road and you see
that sign says 70 miles hour brother you
know that that doesn't mean no
kilometers or you're driving on the
wrong side of the road like they would
in London where [__] Paul McCartney
goes pip pip cheerio on it's Hulk Hogan
meets Chad's dad meets Paul mccarton
dude and he's got a bit of a [__]
sounds a little like lulio when I talk
to him he's a sweet Binky Bonker what's
your favorite Beetle
song Strawberry felds
forever living is easy
with eyes
closed
misunderstanding all you
see it's getting hard to be someone but
it all works out it doesn't matter much
to D that's one of my favorites also I
like Penny Lane sure it's that the the
[__] horns in that God damn I Am The
Walrus is one of my favorites well [__]
okay this is all in all wonderful
wonderful it's it's if only to get uh
younger people people who were not into
the Beatles long ago to get into the
Beatles the greatest band of all time
for my money the greatest Collective of
of of uh members of a of that's what a
band is dude yeah dude it's more than
one person together making music yeah
dude every time we win a ball
game uh and when you listen to Beatles
music you know what there's a [__] ton
of it so no need for this new Beatles
classic or whatever the [__] ch's
talking about over here just go back and
listen to the old
Beatles thank you moving on Beatles at
the sphere that's
happening that's a wrap on episode 80
good work boys 92 luscious points headed
your way that means you're sitting at a
cumulative score of
7,536 so you only have 2,464 more points
before you find out what's going to
happen at
10,000 this week you're both going to
watch something for a watchalong that
will be available on dudy Plus at
patreon.com dudy this Friday afternoon
but I don't know what you're going to
watch yet because the champ gets to
decide so what's it going to be champ
what do you want to
watch okay I never got I had the [__]
belt for 301 episodes I never got to
[__] decide a goddamn watch along y
maybe you should uh maybe you should go
to the YouTube concert and send dudy a
nice note and a video Yeah and maybe
dudy will let starting to understand now
okay all right so earlier in the show
actually that's [__] awesome
Championship has some uh benefits we're
we're finding out now oh I guess you
know whatam oh this is [__]
interesting oh this is [__]
interesting okay okay during halftime I
said we're we're due for a thing we were
both saying we we must be due for one of
these and we're also talking about this
championship title the 10 pounds of
nickel and uh when you talk about
getting something for your victory that
you never had the opportunity to pick
this thing that's not
unlike the material that we will be
watching oh my God this is exactly
what's up okay we used to we we've done
a segment on the show I'm sure we'll do
it again called wrestling and Anime yeah
where uh I watch some anime and Chad
watches a wrestling match and there's
been a match that I have been I've been
hoping that it comes down the pike and
that Chad has to watch it because it's
it's [__] one of the best matches but
it is not a one-on-one match like you've
been used to seeing okay no this is the
Royal Rumble Match now everyone well
well hold on dude everyone knows brother
and the Royal Rumble Match more
contemporarily speaking and I'm talking
about well that's contemporary Beatles
dude that well let me tell you something
dude Jesus Christ that's Beatles what is
it Beatles classic or some [__] but
Royal Rumble now hold on dude dude what
are we watching what are you saying I'm
talking about the Royal
Rumble hold on dude just hold on a
minute dude nowadays in the Royal Rumble
when you win it you get a shot at the
championship at WrestleMania dude and
back in the day probably when this kind
of started
there was a WrestleMania there was a ro
Rumble Match that was so [__]
fantastic and at the end of it a
champion was
crowned and this is what's uh this is
nice it's tying up nicely it's the one
from which I stole that promo and did oh
the Ric Flair thing yeah the Ric Flair
Thing Royal Rumble
1992 uh for my money and many wrestling
nerds out there yes I said nerd Chad I'm
a wrestling nerd nice uhhuh Royal Rumble
199 2 the best Ro Rumble of all time I'm
not going to spoil it if you haven't
seen it but we know that Ric Flair wins
you got to see when he comes in holy
[__] it's so [__] good Hulk Hogan's
in it Macho Man's in it you got so many
of the classics a very young early
Undertaker with the [__] dead man
sort of white face paint Paul Bear oh
yes uh you've got oh [__] you know who's
in this Carrie von Eric uh played by the
guy from the bear Jeremy alen white I
think his name is he plays K vonic in
the new movie the Iron Mask the iron
claw The Mask Iron Mask was well that
was leard Caprio brother yeah yeah dude
that was robero as the mask because he
always wanted that role but no the guy
that Jeremy Allen White from the bear
plays in the movie The Iron Claw is
Kenny Von Eric he's in this [__]
match it's [__] amazing please join
us all right if I know anything about D
it's always 12 noon 12 noon Friday this
will be out we're going to watch Royal
Rumble 1992 in its entirety the Roy the
1992 Royal Rumble Match you're in for it
can't wait oh my god well that's perfect
so this Friday you're both going to
watch the 1992 Royal Rumble match and
I'll have it up on patreon this Friday
afternoon thanks to everyone for joining
us this week until next week call me
[Music]
[Applause]
dudy ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
children of all ages dude Z Generation X
proudly brings to you its podcast
champions of the world the no God Chad
culin the bad sass Willie gun the well
there the New Age
Outlaws the the dude the dudes the D the
dudes after dud I don't know you know
what that is you remember that New Age
Outlaws I don't think so the D DX
Degeneration X the wrestling guys
remember I think my college roommate was
into that or something would suck yeah
good times man a the late 90s early
2000s good stuff you know what we're
going to do we got to watch at an
entrance uh but the road dog Jesse James
and the badass Billy Gun doing a ring
entrance that's one of the things we're
going to get into on this episode of
dudy after dudy because it's D A dudy
after dudy the the mood is a little more
chill the lights are down and we're just
we're just hanging out we're two dudes
[__] around always especially right
now you know what I mean welcome to dudy
after dudy the flagship weekly show of
dudy plus you can join us at patreon.com
dudy this is another barn burner boys
good problems to have if you'll excuse
me I'm just going to get to tabulating
enjoy yourselves this is dudy after
dudy all right well it is dudy after
dudy and uh the next dude's evening is
coming up oh yeah that's right you about
this we still have of course uh dude's
evening Stout is available at uh our
link tree link tre.com dudes hit the
Stout button yeah we still got that but
there's another uh tradition of dude's
evening that is very important what's
that there were I think eight ways of
dudes evening yeah the eight in our
first dudes evening last uh year one of
those ways is the way of the present you
know about this I remember the way of
the present last dude's evening we gave
each other gifts you gave me a water
bottle that I still use I keep it in my
truck all the time and I gave you an
album an LP that you will never play
because you don't have a record player I
almost bought a record player uh but I
have recently got something picked
something up in service of the way of
the present do you know what it is no
what is
it tell a friend then R
rev if you like d what you
do please tell a friend then
do please